其他人：你是经常买还是现在刷短视频
Others: Do you buy often or just watch short videos now?
Tasha: 哈哈哈我我是经常买
Tasha: Haha, I buy often.
其他人： 经常买比较实用
Others: Buying often is more practical.
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Lucia: 你估算的这个大小准吗
Lucia: Are you sure about the size you estimated?
Jake:也还行吧
Jake: It's alright, I guess.
Lucia: 也还行差别不是特别大对
Lucia: It's alright, the difference isn't that big, right?
Jake:海关如果没把我镊子给收
Jake: If customs hadn't taken my tweezers...
Jake:了我现在就能用镊子
Jake: I could use them now.
Jake:就是海关把我
Jake: Customs took my...
Jake:呃就是就是
Jake: Uh, just...
Lucia: 哦
Lucia: Oh.
Jake:那那那螺丝刀哦
Jake: That, that screwdriver...
Jake:里边有很细的那种
Jake: There's a very fine one inside.
Jake:这个还行吧
Jake: This one should be fine.
Alice:没有这个
Alice: Not this one.
Alice:原味是最好吃的
Alice: The original flavor is the best.
Lucia: 哦你哦
Lucia: Oh, you...
Lucia: 你居然能把这一边折上
Lucia: You can actually fold this side up?
Lucia: 慢慢的还行
Lucia: Slowly, it's fine.
Jake:试试试试
Jake: Try it, try it.
Jake:看看行不行
Jake: See if it works.
Jake:如果疼我们再包一层
Jake: If it hurts, we'll wrap another layer.
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Hmm.
Alice:这是岫玉
Alice: This is Xiuyu jade.
Alice:不是翡翠
Alice: Not jadeite.
Alice:就不在你那个评价体系里面
Alice: So it's not in your evaluation system.
其他人：也是一个董哥
Others: There's also a Brother Dong.
Alice:确实先这样吧
Alice: Indeed, let's just leave it like this.
Tasha: 借过一下
Tasha: Excuse me.
Tasha: 但是我又需要一双眼镜布
Tasha: But I need another glasses cloth.
Tasha: 哎我刚才用了眼镜布
Tasha: Hey, I just used the glasses cloth.
Lucia: 算了
Lucia: Forget it.
Jake:怎么都乱扔东西了
Jake: Why is everyone throwing things around?
Tasha: 谁骂人啊
Tasha: Who's cursing?
Jake:我我我我对不起对不起我乱扔
Jake: I, I, I... I'm sorry, I'm sorry, I threw things around.
其他人：算什么什么算什么
Others: What is what?
Alice:什么算什么
Alice: What is what?
Alice:他是怎么来的
Alice: How did he come?
其他人： 也是开石头的吗
Others: Also cracking stones?
Lucia: 也是开石头
Lucia: Also cracking stones.
其他人：你开过石头吗
Others: Have you ever cracked stones?
Tasha: 我没开过石头
Tasha: I have never cracked stones.
其他人：我怎么说我
Others: How do I say I...
其他人：我就给你几块石头你看一看
Others: I'll give you a few stones to look at.
Tasha: 哪有啊我
Tasha: Where do I...
Tasha: 我不会挑石头
Tasha: I don't know how to pick stones.
Tasha: 我会挑榴莲
Tasha: I know how to pick durians.
Tasha: 挑石头还得再练几年
Tasha: Picking stones takes a few more years of practice.
其他人：我便宜卖你
Others: I'll sell them to you cheap.
Alice:哈哈哈我晚上去挑一个
Alice: Haha, I'll go pick one tonight.
其他人：我晚上去挑一个
Others: I'll go pick one tonight.
Tasha: 善哥您是要开始想做蛋糕是吗
Tasha: Brother Shan, are you planning to start making a cake?
其他人：对啊
Others: Yeah.
Tasha: 您先把这个洗了吧
Tasha: First, wash this.
其他人：哪个
Others: Which one?
Tasha: 就这个
Tasha: This one.
其他人：这个
Others: This one?
其他人：您确定要用这个
Others: Are you sure you want to use this?
其他人：哈哈不用就可以不洗
Others: Haha, if not, then you don't need to wash it.
Tasha: 哦那那用的就这个吧
Tasha: Oh, then let's use this one.
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
其他人：教我点假东西
Others: Teach me something fake.
Tasha: 好
Tasha: Okay.
Tasha: 教你点假的
Tasha: I'll teach you something fake.
其他人：天天教我假的
Others: You always teach me fake stuff.
Alice:哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahaha.
Tasha: 你有一天学过吗
Tasha: Have you ever learned it in one day?
Tasha: 你知道他都学多少了吗
Tasha: Do you know how much he's learned?
Tasha: 你都跟不上他了哈哈哈
Tasha: You can't even keep up with him, haha.
Alice:哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahaha.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha.
Jake:怎么能
Jake: How can...
Alice:写经在楼上吗
Alice: Is the scripture upstairs?
Jake:上去给你瞅一个
Jake: I'll take you up to see one.
其他人：昨天学了
Others: Learned it yesterday.
其他人：昨天学金铲铲啊
Others: Learned golden shovel yesterday.
其他人： 金铲铲你也学会了吧
Others: You learned the golden shovel, right?
Tasha: 你也学会了吧
Tasha: You learned it, right?
Lucia: 嗯我学会了
Lucia: Hmm, I got it.
其他人：我看我看一遍我
Others: Let me see, let me see.
其他人：做今天来做肉松小贝鸡蛋
Others: Today we're making meat floss egg cakes.
其他人：这是多少
Others: How many is this?
其他人：这是几个
Others: How many are there?
其他人：6个
Others: Six.
其他人：武林秘籍
Others: Martial arts secret manual.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
其他人：为什么糖是5块钱
Others: Why is the sugar 5 bucks?
其他人：加到面对一斤面粉
Others: Add it to a pound of flour.
其他人：准备找他
Others: Get it ready.
其他人：准备就是昨天晚上准备问他要啊
Others: We were supposed to ask him for it last night.
其他人：他说要收我3,000块
Others: He said he would charge me 3,000 bucks.
其他人：我想想算了
Others: I thought, forget it.
其他人：一块混到一起
Others: Mix it all together.
Lucia: 才卖你3,000块还嫌贵
Lucia: He only charged you 3,000 bucks and you think it's expensive?
其他人：还嫌贵 50块香水
Others: You think it's expensive? 50 bucks for perfume.
其他人：我说打折价
Others: I said it’s a discounted price.
Tasha: 你可以在新加坡独步天下了
Tasha: You could dominate Singapore with that.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Alice:你3,000买的秘籍
Alice: You bought the manual for 3,000.
Alice:你300卖出去
Alice: Sell it for 300.
Alice:你卖100 你净赚
Alice: Sell it for 100, pure profit.
Lucia: 你可以做成
Lucia: You can do it.
Lucia: 做成电子版
Lucia: Make an electronic version.
Lucia: 然后就是以300块钱卖电子版
Lucia: Then sell the electronic version for 300 each.
Lucia: 你可以卖无数个
Lucia: You can sell countless copies.
Lucia: 一本万利啊
Lucia: Huge profits.
Tasha: 那个的话
Tasha: In that case,
Tasha: 用厨房纸巾擦会擦的更干净点
Tasha: Using kitchen paper will clean it better.
其他人：你要用哪个
Others: Which one do you want to use?
Tasha: 在楼上就用这个
Tasha: If you're upstairs, use this one.
其他人：就用这个
Others: Use this one.
Lucia: 什么厨房纸
Lucia: What kitchen paper?
Lucia: 在楼上吗
Lucia: Upstairs?
Jake:在楼上吧
Jake: Upstairs, right?
Alice:在楼上
Alice: upstairs.
其他人：你要在这做就在这
Others: If you want to do it here, do it here.
Tasha: 就在这呀
Tasha: Right here.
Jake:二楼煎牛排
Jake:二楼开火
其他人：哎那我是不是要煎牛排
Others: Oh, should I cook the steak?
Jake:你你可以煎牛排
Jake: Yeah, you can cook the steak.
Jake:也可以或者你也
Jake: Or you can also...
Tasha: 这些杯子都拿走吧
Tasha: Let's take these cups away.
Jake:你也可以先和和面
Jake: You can also knead the dough first.
Jake:然后再去煎牛排
Jake: Then cook the steak later.
其他人：戴个眼镜
Others: Wear glasses.
其他人：煎牛排
Others: Cook the steak.
Jake:可以
Jake: Sure.
Tasha: 这些杯子拿走
Tasha: Take these cups away.
Tasha: 他很危险
Tasha: It's dangerous.
Jake:眼镜我可以站你旁边给你拍
Jake: I can stand next to you and film you with glasses on.
其他人：这个餐具每每个游客来这都要都要用
Others: Every tourist who comes here has to use this tableware.
其他人：我感觉没什么人会用这点餐具吧
Others: I don't think many people will use this tableware.
其他人：那不好说
Others: That's hard to say.
其他人：谁出来玩还多东西
Others: Who would bring a lot of stuff while traveling?
其他人：那不好说
Others: That's hard to say.
其他人：人家给你准备用钱
Others: Maybe they plan to spend money on it.
其他人：你先先问一下他是不是这个吧
Others: Why don't you ask him first if this is the right one?
其他人：今天修硕下的1.7
Others: Today Shure downloaded 1.7.
其他人：不是还1.2G的
Others: Wasn't it also 1.2G?
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Lucia: 至少先有点进展是吧
Lucia: At least there's some progress, right?
Lucia: 至于进展怎么样的
Lucia: As for how it progresses...
其他人：他他他对你说话的语气好轻蔑
Others: The way he talks to you is so condescending.
其他人：你要反击他
Others: You should fight back.
Tasha: 没有没有
Tasha: No, no.
Tasha: 我是我是说他居然知道这个
Tasha: I'm just saying he actually knows this.
Tasha: 做甜品是需要无油无水的
Tasha: Making desserts requires no oil and no water.
Lucia: 好厉害啊
Lucia: That's impressive.
Lucia: 你说的是那种吸水纸吧
Lucia: Are you talking about that absorbent paper?
Lucia: 但是我们只找到了这个
Lucia: But we only found this.
Tasha: 这个吗
Tasha: This one?
Lucia: 在那啊OK
Lucia: There it is, okay.
Jake:好的
Jake: Alright.
Lucia: 我还以为这个在楼上
Lucia: I thought it was upstairs.
Lucia: 我记得你好像买了一卷这个
Lucia: I remember you bought a roll of this.
Jake:先打过来
Jake: Send it over first.
Lucia: 那个那个超好用
Lucia: This one is super useful.
Lucia: 特别好用
Lucia: It's really useful.
其他人：只要一摔了就不好摔了
Others: As soon as it falls, it's no longer easy to drop.
其他人：应该拿上毫无生活经验的标签
Others: It should come with a label saying "no life experience."
其他人：：哈哈哈你这个范为什么这么短
Others: Hahaha, why is your version so short?
其他人：我觉得很难很难拿
Others: I think it's really hard to grab.
Tasha: 这把为什么这么短
Tasha: Why is this one so short?
Tasha: 是的呢要不你去让厂家生产改一下
Tasha: Yeah, maybe you should ask the manufacturer to make some adjustments.
其他人：好你买的
Others: Okay, you buy it.
其他人：不对好你买的
Others: No, seriously, you buy it.
Tasha: 好你买的肯定比我好
Tasha: Sure, your purchase is definitely better than mine.
Tasha: 哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahahaha.
其他人:一句都说不出来
Others: Can't say a word.
Tasha: 要开始了是吗
Tasha: Is it starting now?
Tasha: 这这就要开始了是吗
Tasha: Is it really starting now?
其他人：不然呢
Others: What else?
其他人：要不让他先说
Others: How about letting him speak first?
其他人：你怕我怕我怕我怕
Others: I'm scared, I'm scared, I'm scared.
其他人：不好
Others: Not good.
其他人：我很会做饭
Others: I'm really good at cooking.
Jake:哈哈
Jake: Haha.
Tasha: 你很会做饭好
Tasha: You're really good at cooking, huh?
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
其他人：那个相机开了
Others: That camera is on.
Jake:开了闪了
Jake: It's on and flashing.
Jake:就是开了他
Jake: It's definitely on.
qtr :我也不懂为什么
qtr: I don't understand why either.
Jake:反正他是开了
Jake: Anyway, it's on.
Jake:每个相机都有自己的个性
Jake: Every camera has its own personality.
其他人: 这不是check一个吗
Others: Isn't this just checking one?
Jake:对是
Jake: Yes, it is.
Jake:我们主要check他
Jake: We're mainly checking it.
Jake:充电宝上面的灯和字是不是亮的
Jake: Are the lights and text on the power bank lit up?
Jake:关了就就不行
Jake: If it's off, it won't work.
Tasha: 都可以啊怎么用都可以
Tasha: It's all fine, you can use it however you want.
Tasha: 鸡蛋呢
Tasha: Where are the eggs?
其他人:有可能是打
Others: Maybe it's a hit.
其他人:但是你别先打
Others: But don't hit it first.
其他人:你要你要打他一会就就该教育你了
Others: If you hit it, you'll get a lecture later.
其他人:我就不会
Others: I wouldn't do it.
Jake:他不理你
Jake: He won't care about you.
其他人:他竟然没说呢
Others: He didn't say anything!
Jake:他竟然没说呢
Jake: He didn't say anything!
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha
其他人:在推测哈哈
Others: Guessing, haha
Jake:他不理你怎么办
Jake: What if he ignores you?
其他人:他不理我就打
Others: If he ignores me, I'll hit him.
Jake:好的哈哈哈
Jake: Okay, hahaha
Alice:今天晚上做提拉米苏吗
Alice: Are we making tiramisu tonight?
Tasha: 是的呢哈哈哈
Tasha: Yes, haha
Alice:那个
Alice: Um...
Jake:确实打
Jake: Definitely hit him.
Jake:打了一个手蛋
Jake: Hit him with an egg.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Tasha: 啊那个是手的
Tasha: Oh, that's by hand.
Jake:对打不出蛋黄
Jake: Yeah, can't get the yolk out.
Alice:哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Tasha: 哎
Tasha: Hey
Alice:要用蛋清
Alice: You need the egg white.
其他人：要什么我还没加呢
Others: Need what? I haven't added it yet.
其他人：哈哈哈你怎么可能带着咳嗽
Others: Hahaha, how can you be coughing?
其他人：哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Others: Hahahahahahahahaha
其他人：打那个碗里
Others: Beat it in the bowl.
Tasha: 那个打蛋盆呢
Tasha: Where's the mixing bowl?
其他人：先把鸡蛋加进去
Others: Add the eggs first.
Tasha: 打蛋盆呢
Tasha: Where's the mixing bowl?
Alice:在这么
Alice: Over here.
Jake:有它都有
Jake: Got everything.
Jake:那确实
Jake: Indeed.
Jake:易烊千玺哎
Jake: Yi Yangqianxi, hey.
Jake:我们好像是什么时候看到的那个王源
Jake: When did we see Wang Yuan?
Jake:还是哦
Jake: Or was it...
其他人：是那个去去去
Others: He went to...
其他人：买瑞幸coffee的哦
Others: Buy Luckin Coffee, oh.
其他人:买芙蓉王时能看到王源
Others: You can see Wang Yuan when buying Furongwang.
其他人:芙蓉王源
Others: Furongwang Yuan.
其他人:尼古丁丁
Others: Nicotine Ding.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
其他人:坏了我们顺序要少于顺序
Others: Oh no, our order is wrong.
其他人:TF不好意思
Others: TF, sorry.
其他人:我北半球我能收获一大批
Others: In the Northern Hemisphere, I can harvest a big batch.
Tasha: 用了
Tasha: Used it.
Tasha: 有淡奶油的味道
Tasha: It has a cream taste.
Tasha: 没擦干
Tasha: Didn't wipe it dry.
Tasha: 这个要保持绝对的干
Tasha: This needs to be completely dry.
其他人:欧欧奥来讲还是赚哈哈哈
Others: Oh, it's still a profit haha.
Lucia: 哈
Lucia: Ha.
其他人: 这打蛋器你要不来打
Others: Do you want to use this mixer?
Tasha: 你要不来打
Tasha: Do you want to use it?
其他人：只加蛋清
Others: Just add egg whites.
Jake:他会打他来打
Jake: He knows how to mix, let him do it.
Tasha: 打到打到这里面
Tasha: Mix it in here.
其他人：打几个
Others: How many to mix?
Jake:他可会打了
Jake: He’s really good at mixing.
其他人：只加蛋清
Others: Just add egg whites.
Tasha: 不用你打进去就行了
Tasha: No need, just mix it in.
Jake:直接打直接打
Jake: Just mix it directly.
其他人：他用手给你打
Others: He’ll mix it by hand for you.
其他人：蛋黄弄出来
Others: Separate the yolk.
其他人：这么高级可以
Others: So advanced, nice.
Jake:可以
Jake: Nice.
其他人：蛋壳不要了
Others: Discard the eggshells.
Tasha: 蛋壳不要了
Tasha: Discard the eggshells.
其他人：：我来打个
Others: Let me mix one.
Tasha: 哎等等等等
Tasha: Hey, wait, wait, wait.
Tasha: 我怕打坏了
Tasha: I'm afraid I'll mess it up.
Lucia: 要要一个蛋就倒一次
Lucia: Just one egg, pour once.
Tasha: 哈哈不然的话后果很严重
Tasha: Haha, otherwise the consequences will be serious.
其他人：又怕我打坏了
Others: Also afraid I’ll mess it up.
Tasha: OK第二位学徒上场
Tasha: OK, second apprentice on stage.
Jake:OK第二位学徒上场就其他人：
Jake: OK, second apprentice on stage, others:
Tasha: 不用你直接报就行了
Tasha: No need, just report directly.
Jake:秀手法这是手法
Jake: Show your skills, this is technique.
Jake:这是
Jake: This is...
Alice:你别把蛋黄弄破了
Alice: Don't break the egg yolk.
其他人:他必须要展示一下
Others: He must show off a bit.
Tasha: 你把蛋黄弄破了你就死定了
Tasha: If you break the yolk, you're dead.
Jake:活着还活着
Jake: Still alive, still alive.
其他人：我靠牛啊
Others: Wow, amazing.
Alice:哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahahaha
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha
Jake:傻子呀哈哈哈
Jake: You idiot, hahaha
Lucia: 膨胀了膨胀了
Lucia: Getting too confident, huh
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Jake:你这有变化吗
Jake: Any changes?
Jake:你这来回倒
Jake: You're going back and forth
Tasha: 了这蛋黄
Tasha: The yolk
Tasha: 到这哎
Tasha: Over here, hey
Tasha: 干嘛
Tasha: What are you doing
Tasha: 蛋清蛋清到底
Tasha: The egg white, the egg white, come on
其他人: 需要这个完整
Others: We need it whole
Tasha: 嗯好
Tasha: Okay
Tasha: 下一个下一个
Tasha: Next one, next one
Tasha: 谁要打不敢打
Tasha: Who wants to hit it, don't be scared
Jake:下一个来来来来来来
Jake: Next one, come on, come on, come on
Lucia: 我不敢打
Lucia: I'm scared to hit it
其他人:来来来我不敢打
Others: Come on, come on, I'm scared to hit it
Tasha: 我已经不敢打了
Tasha: I'm already scared to hit it
Alice:我已经不敢打了
Alice: I'm already scared to hit it
其他人:我只能打打
Others: I can only hit it a bit
其他人:打进去就不错了
Others: It's good if it goes in
其他人:你别把蛋黄打碎
Others: Don't break the yolk
其他人:切都没有问题
Others: Cutting is fine
Alice:完整
Alice: Whole
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh
Lucia: 哦
Lucia: Oh
其他人:各显神通
Others: Show your skills
Jake:是
Jake: Yes
Alice:哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Alice:哦到你了
Alice: Oh, it's your turn
Alice:快了我感觉哈哈哈
Alice: Almost there, I feel, hahaha
Jake:哈玩玩球
Jake: Haha, play with the ball
Jake:哎可以可以
Jake: Hey, nice, nice
其他人：我有些紧张
Others: I'm a bit nervous
Jake:没关系没关系没关系
Jake: It's okay, it's okay, it's okay
Jake:可以可以
Jake: It's okay, it's okay
Jake:一定成功
Jake: You'll succeed for sure
Alice:有有有在这呢
Alice: There, there, there it is
Jake:可以成功
Jake: It can be done.
Alice:给给你玩会
Alice: Here, give it a try.
其他人:我只会最基础的
Others: I only know the basics.
其他人:因为因为当我需要打鸡蛋的时候
Others: Because when I need to crack eggs...
Alice:呃要接一个
Alice: Uh, need to take one.
其他人:只会用来炒鸡蛋
Others: I can only use it to make scrambled eggs.
Alice:那个转子啊在这
Alice: The rotor is here.
其他人:哦这是这个是吧
Others: Oh, this is it, right?
Alice:对对对
Alice: Yes, yes.
其他人：哎呦我操那个没事
Others: Oh gosh, it's fine.
Tasha: 你应该知道
Tasha: You should know.
Lucia: 那必须已经非常熟练了
Lucia: You must be very skilled by now.
Alice:玩吧非常熟练了
Alice: Play with it, you're very skilled now.
Jake:可以出师
Jake: You can graduate.
其他人:他干嘛去
Others: Where is he going?
其他人:我好高级
Others: I feel so advanced.
其他人:感觉非常厉害
Others: It feels really impressive.
其他人:卧槽我要学一下打五个单
Others: Whoa, I need to learn to crack five eggs at once.
其他人:五个蛋试一下
Others: Try cracking five eggs.
Jake:你直接配就好了
Jake: Just mix it directly.
Tasha: 50克清水
Tasha: 50 grams of water.
Jake:围观
Jake: Watch.
其他人:哎那个单
Others: Hey, that order.
其他人：我之前你这个打单
Others: I previously cracked that order.
其他人:你这个打单可以打多长时间
Others: How long can you crack that order?
其他人:20分钟吗
Others: 20 minutes?
Alice:20分钟都打服了
Alice: 20 minutes and it's done.
Tasha: 最高5分钟都打到
Tasha: At most 5 minutes and it's done.
Tasha: 不能再打了
Tasha: No more cracking.
其他人:我在我家
Others: At my house...
其他人:我自己打篮球怎么打都打不起来
Others: I can never make a shot when playing basketball alone.
其他人:你自己还打嗯
Others: You still play on your own?
其他人:加加加多少
Others: How much to add?
其他人:这个怎么锁
Others: How to lock this?
其他人:你把你的配料贡献出来
Others: Contribute your ingredients.
其他人:就他有在这吗
Others: Is he here?
Lucia: 就他有一个花
Lucia: He has a flower.
Lucia: 你那按进去
Lucia: Press it in.
Lucia: 对顺着他就就按一下就可以了
Lucia: Yes, just follow it and press it.
其他人:哦看到了然后呢
Others: Oh, I see it, then what?
Alice:按比例
Lucia: 对按进去只要他不掉就他就按上了
Lucia: Yes, press it in as long as it doesn't fall out.
其他人：这么高级
Others: So advanced.
Lucia: 对就已经好了
Lucia: Yes, it's already done.
Tasha: 大家都看着我
Tasha: Everyone's looking at me.
Tasha: 我有点紧张了
Tasha: I'm a bit nervous now.
Jake:对啊这是一代宗师和门下弟子
Jake: Yeah, this is a grandmaster and his disciples.
Tasha: 哈哈哈我想要矿泉水
Tasha: Hahaha, I want mineral water.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Tasha: 清水水
Tasha: Pure water.
Jake:好师傅想喝水
Jake: Okay, the master wants to drink water.
Jake:哈哈哈矿泉水
Jake: Hahaha, mineral water.
Tasha: 不是我想喝水这药水
Tasha: No, I want to drink this potion.
Lucia: 我们有接
Lucia: We have it.
Lucia: 这个也行吧
Lucia: This one works too, right?
Lucia: 这是纯净水吗
Lucia: Is this purified water?
Lucia: 那行
Lucia: Okay.
Lucia: 我记得刚刚应该有几个杯子
Lucia: I remember there were a few cups just now.
Lucia: 是我洗过的
Lucia: I washed them.
Lucia: 是这个吗
Lucia: Is it this one?
Lucia: 管他呢冲一下
Lucia: Whatever, just rinse it.
Tasha: 哎干什么
Tasha: Hey, what are you doing?
Jake:比划比划
Jake: Just measuring.
Jake:电脑没插
Jake: The computer isn't plugged in.
Tasha: 等会给你用
Tasha: I'll let you use it later.
其他人:那个打蛋的呢
Others: Where's the egg beater?
其他人:那个去哪里了
Others: Where did it go?
其他人：多了
Others: Too much.
其他人:有关系吗
Others: Does it matter?
Jake:喝掉
Jake: Drink it.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
其他人：多少水啊
Others: How much water?
其他人:你不去皮吗
Others: Aren't you peeling it?
其他人:清水加50110
Others: Add 50110 of pure water.
其他人:然后100
Others: Then 100.
其他人:多多奖励
Others: More rewards.
Alice:无妨
Alice: No problem.
Tasha: 您来搅
Tasha: You stir.
Lucia: 个不用哈哈哈
Lucia: No need, hahaha.
Tasha: 不用
Tasha: No need
Tasha: 不要哈哈
Tasha: Don't haha
Lucia: 不要那个这么小的碗会打飞出去吗
Lucia: Don't use that, such a small bowl will fly away
Jake:对
Jake: Yes
其他人:搅到什么程度
Others: To what extent should we stir it?
Tasha: 找到他们俩完全融合
Tasha: Until they completely blend together
其他人:水和油还能融合吗
Others: Can water and oil even blend together?
Jake:就是可以融合
Jake: They can blend
Jake:师傅说可以融合
Jake: The master said they can blend
Shure: 好这不违反牛顿算什么
Shure: Well, if this doesn't violate Newton's laws, what does?
Jake:牛顿算什么
Jake: What does Newton know?
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Alice:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahahahahaha
Tasha: 哈
Tasha: Ha
Tasha: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahahahahahahaha
其他人:给师傅埋进去
Others: Bury the master
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahahahahahahaha
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha
Tasha: 找到完全融合
Tasha: Until it completely blends
其他人:你觉得如何
Others: What do you think?
Tasha: 我觉得没有
Tasha: I don't think so
Shure: 咱俩这辈子他也不可能融合
Shure: It'll never blend in our lifetime
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Haha
其他人：怕他变成金子
Others: Afraid it might turn into gold
Shure: 我从小接受的金是不允许我卖这种金
Shure: Since I was young, I've been told gold can't be sold
其他人：有水混合物
Others: There's a water mixture
Lucia: 哈
Lucia: Ha
其他人:但是变成特别小
Others: But it turns into something very small
其他人:的那种对
Others: Yes, exactly
其他人：确实他只是变成了特别小的那种Alice:
Others: Indeed, it just turns into something very small
其他人:这个时候你给他加一点那个洗衣剂
Others: At this point, you add a bit of detergent
其他人:也就是乳化
Others: That's emulsifying
其他人:哈哈哈别吧还能吃吗
Others: Haha, can we still eat it?
Tasha: 再搅一搅
Tasha: Stir it again
Tasha: 我帮你倒下一个东西
Tasha: I'll help you pour the next thing
其他人:怎么感觉搅成面糊的感觉
Others: Why does it feel like we're making dough?
其他人:那个大的都去哪了
Others: Where did the big ones go?
Lucia: 这个吗在这啊
Lucia: This? It's here
其他人：叫蛋清的啊
Others: It's called egg whites
Lucia: 哦那个在冰箱里
Lucia: Oh, that's in the fridge.
其他人:还要冰一会是吧
Others: It needs to chill a bit longer, right?
Lucia: 对对对他是我们接下来会
Lucia: Yeah, yeah, we'll use it soon.
Lucia: 用到的妙妙小工具
Lucia: It's a handy little tool we'll need.
其他人:你先去皮
Others: You should peel it first.
Tasha: 去了放放
Tasha: Peel it and set it aside.
其他人:你这你这
Others: You're doing it like this?
Tasha: 没关系我知道了
Tasha: It's okay, I got it.
其他人:40.8叫加50
Others: 40.8, add 50.
其他人:多一点多一点
Others: A bit more, a bit more.
其他人:卧槽精益求精
Others: Whoa, attention to detail.
其他人:没事多一点多一点多一点
Others: It's fine, a bit more, a bit more.
其他人:多吃一口
Others: Just one more bite.
Jake:1/500
Jake: 1/500
Tasha: 继续搅
Tasha: Keep stirring.
其他人:我靠可以拿那个打蛋器吗
Others: Wow, can we use the whisk?
Alice:不可以
Alice: No, you can't.
Jake:喜欢打碗的
Jake: Likes to beat bowls.
其他人:这个可以
Others: This one works.
Tasha: 那个太大了
Tasha: That one’s too big.
其他人:这正经面糊这味
Others: This is proper batter.
其他人:纸杯蛋糕
Others: Cupcakes.
Tasha: 不是的
Tasha: No, it’s not.
其他人：那这是哦
Others: What is this then? Oh.
其他人:哦这肉松小
Others: Oh, this is meat floss.
其他人：这是什么东西
Others: What’s this?
Tasha: 玉米淀粉
Tasha: Cornstarch.
其他人:搅了
Others: Mix it.
Jake:不带劲来
Jake: Not exciting enough.
其他人:来看着很有食欲
Others: Looks appetizing.
其他人:我来上脸
Others: I'm putting on a face.
Jake:上点强度
Jake: Add some intensity.
Jake:你这几档的
Jake: What speed is this?
Jake:2档的这5档的这个
Jake: Speed 2, this is speed 5.
其他人:还要加
Others: Add more.
其他人:哎呦我操
Others: Oh my god.
Tasha: 倒到这个里面来吧
Tasha: Pour it in here.
Jake:现在你可以用你的机器了
Jake: Now you can use your machine.
Tasha: 可以用那个蛋抽了
Tasha: You can use the whisk now.
Tasha: 呃那个那个蛋抽不是机器
Tasha: Uh, that egg beater isn't a machine.
Jake:插电了
Jake: Plug it in.
Jake:蛋抽还没到机器
Jake: The egg beater hasn't reached the machine yet.
其他人:这个碗底不要了吗
Others: Don't need the bottom of this bowl?
Lucia: 不用了好
Lucia: No need, it's fine.
其他人:所以说你刚刚进一球就没系列了
Others: So you just scored and there's no series anymore?
其他人:是为了让他配比是不是
Others: Is it to match the ratio?
Alice:配比是对的
Alice: The ratio is correct.
其他人:那个得洗一下
Others: That needs to be washed.
Tasha: 洗了之后用那个厨房纸巾擦一擦
Tasha: After washing, wipe it with kitchen paper.
Tasha: 不要干燥哦
Tasha: Don't dry it, okay?
其他人:配料什么的
Others: What about the ingredients?
Tasha: 什么配料
Tasha: What ingredients?
Alice:我们的快递到了吗
Alice: Has our delivery arrived?
Alice:在哪呢
Alice: Where is it?
Alice:他送过来了吗
Alice: Did he deliver it?
Alice:哦
Alice: Oh.
Alice:有没有刀之类的
Alice: Are there any knives or something?
Alice:算了手撕一样
Alice: Never mind, tear it by hand.
Tasha: 打到现在
Tasha: Beat it until now.
Tasha: 打到他提起来不会掉下来
Tasha: Beat it until it won't fall when lifted.
Tasha: 呃提起来有小弯钩就行
Tasha: Uh, as long as it forms a small hook when lifted.
Tasha: 你没有呢
Tasha: You haven't got it yet.
Tasha: 远远没有
Tasha: Nowhere near.
Jake:哎呦只能只能到店取餐了
Jake: Oh man, we can only pick it up from the store.
Jake:啥意思啊
Jake: What does that mean?
Tasha: 那就找个跑腿喽
Tasha: Then just find a courier.
Tasha: 好再充分搅拌一下就OK了
Tasha: Okay, mix it well again and it's fine.
Tasha: 打发到不能再变大
Tasha: Whip it until it can't get any bigger.
Tasha: 一直打一直打
Tasha: Keep whipping, keep whipping.
Tasha: 打到他不会再变大
Tasha: Whip it until it can't get bigger.
其他人:他已经变大了
Others: It's already gotten bigger.
Tasha: 你他有没有变大嘛
Tasha: Has it gotten bigger?
Tasha: 你说蛋清
Tasha: You mean the egg whites?
Shure: 点不了吧
Shure: Can't order it, right?
Shure: 这是到店取餐
Shure: It's pick-up only.
Tasha: 这两个加起来
Tasha: 打开了
Alice: It's open.
Jake:师傅准备找个跑腿
Jake: The boss is preparing to find a courier.
其他人:离多远我们过去
Others: How far is it? We can go there.
Jake:2.4公里
Jake: 2.4 kilometers
Tasha: 打发到你觉得不能再变大的位置
Tasha: Beat it until you feel it can't get any bigger.
Tasha: 就OK了
Tasha: Then it's okay.
其他人:主要是你打的手法不对
Other: Mainly, your technique is wrong.
其他人:到了
Other: Got it.
Jake:那还能怎么回事啊师傅
Jake: What else could it be, master?
Tasha: 不知道吧
Tasha: Don't know.
Tasha: 算了稀了加粉
Tasha: Forget it, add more flour.
Tasha: 粉了加干了加加水
Tasha: If it's too thin, add more flour and water.
Jake:我觉得你这个更适合
Jake: I think this suits you better.
Shure: 好了好了好了他队在干活
Shure: Alright, alright, alright, his team is working.
Shure: 我操逆天了
Shure: Damn, this is insane.
Shure: 我真扯到波塔了
Shure: I really messed up the tower.
其他人：吓了半天没收到我操
Other: Scared for half a day but didn't receive anything, damn.
Jake:你们公共区域在哪啊
Jake: Where is your common area?
其他人:公共区域应该在台湾区那个什么Patro
Other: The common area should be in the Taiwan zone, something like Patro.
Jake:那你
Jake: Then you...
Jake:那你弄过来呗
Jake: Then bring it over.
其他人:我已经忘了康大该怎么软硬我怎么来
Other: I've already forgotten how to do it softly and firmly.
Lucia: 为什么会
Lucia: Why...
Lucia: 好像没什么变化呀
Lucia: It doesn't seem to change much.
其他人：应该会怎么样
Other: What should it be like?
其他人：应该会特别丑是吗
Other: Should it be really ugly?
Lucia: 理论上会越打越丑好像
Lucia: In theory, it should get uglier.
Jake:你点了吗
Jake: Did you click it?
其他人：确实好吃
Other: It's really delicious.
Tasha: 没关系我看他们用除湿机要打5分钟
Tasha: It's okay, I saw them use a dehumidifier for 5 minutes.
Tasha: 这种手抽机的话可能要打个10分钟吧
Tasha: With this hand mixer, it might take 10 minutes.
Jake:你坐着打吧
Jake: Sit down and beat it.
Jake:要不抱着打吧
Jake: Or hold it and beat it.
Jake:10分钟之后见哈哈
Jake: See you in 10 minutes, haha.
Lucia: 休息一下马上回来
Lucia: Take a break, we'll be right back.
Lucia: 好我们可以卡了哈
Lucia: Okay, we can cut now.
Tasha: 这个状态是很不对的
Tasha: This state is really wrong.
Lucia: 哈
Lucia: Haha.
Alice:买的香薰
Tasha: 如果实在不行
Tasha: If it doesn't work...
Tasha: 那就加面粉吧
Tasha: Then just add flour.
Alice:对
Alice: Right.
Alice:好我现在要开始去装修我的地方了
Alice: Okay, I'm going to start decorating my place now.
Tasha: 再看一看吧
Tasha: Let's take another look.
其他人:水或者什么加太多
Others: Maybe too much water or something.
其他人:什么都没加多呀
Others: I didn't add too much of anything.
Alice:你也要来吗
Alice: Are you coming too?
Alice:可以
Alice: Sure.
Alice:哇还有个快递
Alice: Wow, there's another package.
Lucia: 我一会也去检查一下
Lucia: I'll check mine in a bit too.
Lucia: 我的快递到了啊
Lucia: My package arrived!
Lucia: 你这个好好看啊很森系
Lucia: Yours looks really nice, very forest-themed.
Alice:啊啊
Alice: Ah, ah.
Alice:我刚弄的啊
Alice: I just made this.
Alice:我需要把这个给洗一下
Alice: I need to wash this.
Alice:哎呦我的天呐
Alice: Oh my gosh.
Alice:好沉呀这个
Alice: This is so heavy.
Alice:呀呀呀
Alice: Ah, ah, ah.
Alice:哎呦我的天呐
Alice: Oh my gosh.
Alice:呀
Alice:没事那个是打那个鸡呢
Alice: It's okay, that's just for the chicken.
Lucia: 不会吧不会吧不会吧
Lucia: No way, no way, no way.
Alice:不会吧不会吧不会吧
Alice: No way, no way, no way.
Alice:是不是还是我的呀
Alice: Is it still mine?
Shure: 徒手搓核弹了是吧
Shure: Are you trying to make a nuke by hand?
Lucia: 真的我觉得他
Lucia: Seriously, I think he...
Alice:哎呦我的狗
Alice: Oh my gosh, my dog!
Alice:谁踢了我的狗
Alice: Who kicked my dog?
Tasha: 玉米淀粉用可可塔塔粉代替了呀
Tasha: So we replaced corn starch with cream of tartar?
Alice:啊我没点
Alice: Oh, I didn’t order it.
Tasha: 这个的托呢
Tasha: Where’s the tray for this?
Tasha: 好了你不知道在哪
Tasha: Alright, you don’t know where it is.
其他人：我怎么闻到了一股加热的味道
Others: Why do I smell something heating up?
Jake:好像预热
Jake: It seems to be preheating.
Tasha: 哇哇
Tasha: Wow, wow.
Jake:预热中
Jake: Preheating.
Alice:你点了吗没呢
Alice: Did you turn it on or not?
Lucia: 没呢
Lucia: No, I didn’t.
Lucia: 哎我们现在吃的是奥麦当劳啊
Lucia: Hey, are we eating from McDonald's now?
Tasha: 没事没事没事找个托我们开始加热吧
Tasha: It’s okay, it’s okay. Find a tray and we’ll start heating.
Jake:托找不到找不着
Jake: Can’t find the tray.
Jake:托是在这里头吗
Jake: Is the tray in here?
Tasha: 那那怎么办呢
Tasha: Then what should we do?
Jake:是在这里头
Jake: It's in here.
Jake:哎呦我靠
Jake: Oh my gosh.
Tasha: 是在这里头吗
Tasha: Is it in here?
Tasha: 搁哪呢
Tasha: Where is it?
Jake:不知道啊
Jake: No idea.
Tasha: 你翻一翻呀
Tasha: Try searching!
Tasha: 扒拉扒拉呀
Tasha: Dig around!
Tasha: 哇靠哈哈
Tasha: Whoa, haha!
Jake:啊哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Ahahaha.
Jake:还好还好还好皮厚
Jake: Good thing, good thing it's thick-skinned.
Jake:我靠我靠师傅直接一刀
Jake: Oh my, the master just slashed it.
Jake:哈哈师傅刀我靠
Jake: Haha, the master's knife, wow.
Jake:直接抽我一刀
Jake: Just slashed me with a knife.
其他人：砍一刀
Others: A slash.
Jake:砍一刀还好还好皮厚
Jake: A slash, but it's okay, thick skin.
Tasha: 没有
Tasha: No.
Alice:没有嗯
Alice: No, hmm.
其他人：确实没有
Others: Definitely no.
Tasha: 没有怎么办
Tasha: What do we do if there's none?
其他人:刀太炖了好烫
Others: The knife is too dull, it's hot.
其他人:没有直接倒进去
Others: If none, just pour it in.
Tasha: 不行
Tasha: No way.
其他人:拿手固定呗
Others: Just hold it with your hand.
Katrina: 好香啊
Katrina: Smells so good.
其他人：是这个味吗是
Others: Is this the smell? Yes.
其他人：哎
Others: Hey.
其他人：为什么鸡蛋一打打打开了就这么香呢
Others: Why does the egg smell so good when cracked open?
Tasha: 这不是鸡蛋的问题吧
Tasha: It's not the egg's problem, right?
其他人:那是哪个香
Others: Then what smells good?
Tasha: 没有
Tasha: No.
其他人：蛋糕粉香
Others: The cake mix smells good.
其他人：蛋糕哎
Others: Cake, hey.
其他人：蛋糕粉也不香
Others: The cake mix doesn't smell good either.
其他人：糖香加了糖吧
Others: The sugar smells good, added sugar.
Tasha: 汤和鸡蛋
Tasha: Soup and eggs.
Tasha: 从高处没过筛呢
Tasha: Didn't sift it from high up.
Tasha: 搞什么呢
Tasha: What are you doing?
Tasha: 筛网
Tasha: Sieve.
Shure: 好香啊
Shure: Smells so good.
Shure: 我们是不是应该一会排练一下
Shure: Should we rehearse a bit later?
Alice:嗯这个有这个的
Alice: Hmm, this one has this.
Shure: 明天的歌曲
Shure: Tomorrow's song.
Katrina: 哦忘了哈哈哈
Katrina: Oh, I forgot, haha.
Shure: 工人怎么变批人了这两天
Shure: Why have the workers turned into batches of people these days?
Alice:这个有这个可乐给你吧哦行了
Alice: This one has this. Here, have a Coke. Oh, alright.
Katrina: 再待两天
Katrina: Stay for two more days.
Lucia: 啊行啊
Lucia: Ah, okay.
Katrina: 我完蛋了哈哈
Katrina: I'm doomed, haha.
Jake:一个坯房啊这是一个坯房啊
Jake: A rough house, this is a rough house.
Alice:我看我买的啥
Alice: Let me see what I bought.
Jake:进来的人一定是坯人
Jake: Anyone who comes in must be rough.
Alice:厚牛堡
Alice: Thick beef burger.
Katrina: 嗯我要完蛋了
Katrina: Hmm, I'm gonna be doomed.
Alice:好了
Alice: Alright.
Jake:点完了都点完了都点了
Jake: Ordered, everything is ordered.
Lucia: 我还没点
Lucia: I haven't ordered yet.
Jake:哦好你选哪一個
Jake: Oh, okay, which one do you want?
其他人:咱们往里面加点那个
Others: Let's add some of that inside.
Tasha: 你这么爱吃菠萝吗
Tasha: Do you love eating pineapples that much?
其他人:但是我不知道他家烤菜是不是我一样
Others: But I don't know if their grilled dishes are the same as mine.
其他人:用的烤菠萝
Others: Using grilled pineapple.
Tasha: 拿12个
Tasha: Take 12 of them.
Tasha: 把托找一下行吗
Tasha: Can you find the tray?
Jake:把什么托
Jake: Which tray?
Tasha: 托
Tasha: The tray.
Jake:对我在找托
Jake: Yes, I'm looking for the tray.
其他人:那我就不客气了
Others: Then I won't be polite.
Tasha: 这个蛋挞很简单
Tasha: This egg tart is really simple.
Tasha: 来个简单的
Tasha: Let's do a simple one.
Tasha: 这个我做过好多遍
Tasha: I've made this many times.
Tasha: 提拉米苏也做过好多遍
Tasha: I've also made tiramisu many times.
Tasha: 这两个不会失败的
Tasha: These two won't fail.
Tasha: 还买了一个专业的
Tasha: I even bought a professional one.
Jake:这蓝莓怎么这么丑啊
Jake: Why are these blueberries so ugly?
Tasha: 我我我好像学会了
Tasha: I think I got it.
Tasha: 看你这样操作
Tasha: Watching you do it like this.
Tasha: 你还记得吗
Tasha: Do you still remember?
Tasha: 那天我们明明一起把那个托
Tasha: That day we clearly put the tray together.
Tasha: 盘削在这的结果就不见了
Tasha: But it just disappeared.
Katrina: 有人要去取快递吗
Katrina: Anyone going to pick up the package?
Jake:啊他可以现在单独去取吗
Jake: Ah, can he go get it by himself now?
Lucia: 他说他现在忙不过来
Lucia: He said he's too busy right now.
Jake:那
Jake: Then...
Jake:他说让自己取是吧
Jake: He said we should get it ourselves, right?
Tasha: 点什么还在点吗
Tasha: What are you ordering? Still ordering?
Tasha: 500多块钱怎么吃到500多的
Tasha: How did we end up with over 500 bucks?
Tasha: 我靠这个人谁
Tasha: Whoa, who is this person?
Tasha: 太过分了
Tasha: This is too much.
Tasha: 吃一个77块钱的套餐
Tasha: Ordering a 77 bucks meal.
Tasha: 我只吃了那个22块钱的套餐
Tasha: I only got the 22 bucks meal.
Tasha: 你把这个麦津会员开了是吗
Tasha: Did you get the McJin membership?
Tasha: 因为他写他只要19块钱
Tasha: Because it says it's only 19 bucks.
Tasha: 但他这一单可以减37块5
Tasha: But with this order, we can save 37.5 bucks.
Tasha: 我靠怎么会买到56068块钱
Tasha: Whoa, how did we end up buying 56068 bucks worth?
其他人：咱多少咱这么多人
Others: How many of us are there?
Tasha: 那好吧
Tasha: Alright then.
Jake:咱总共9个
Jake: There are 9 of us.
Alice:是不是有的套餐那个啥
Alice: Is there something wrong with the package?
Jake:10个人咱总共10个人
Jake: 10 people, there are 10 of us in total.
Alice:超过一份就原价了还是怎么样
Alice: Does it go back to the original price if we exceed one?
Tasha: 太离谱了
Tasha: This is ridiculous.
Jake:9个人嘛
Jake: 9 people, right?
Alice:哎呦卧槽那么滑
Alice: Whoa, that's so slippery!
Alice:哒哒哒
Alice: Da da da.
Alice:应该还有我的一个啊
Alice: There should be one more of mine.
Alice:小什么
Alice: What was it again?
Alice:坏了
Alice: Oh no.
Tasha: 买可贵了
Tasha: Bought it too expensive.
Tasha: 蛋挞上面应该随便加8的蛋挞
Tasha: The egg tarts should come with 8 more egg tarts on top.
其他人:蛋挞不会只有一人一个吧
Others: There's only one egg tart per person, right?
其他人:还真一人
Others: Actually, it's one per person.
Tasha: 12个
Tasha: 12 of them.
其他人:差不多一个
Others: About one each.
Tasha: 一人吃一个还不够吗
Tasha: One per person isn't enough?
Tasha: 你真想吃的话咱们就烤24个
Tasha: If you really want more, we can bake 24 of them.
Jake:有很多可以代替剪刀的东西
Jake: There are many things that can replace scissors.
Jake:所以为什么呢
Jake: So why?
Jake:为什么不填他就最高评价了
Jake: Why not fill it in, and then it's the highest rating.
其他人:很不甜比较健康
Others: It's not very sweet, healthier.
其他人:比较健康
Others: Healthier.
其他人:就是不甜中
Others: It's just not sweet
其他人:你们能感感受到
Others: Can you feel it?
其他人:这个糖给你带来的愉悦
Others: The joy this candy brings you?
Jake:好我收回我的话上海
Jake: Okay, I take back what I said about Shanghai
其他人:上海人那么机器真好用
Others: Shanghai people's machines are really good
Alice:雨轩你有没有买一个地毯绿色的
Alice: Yuxuan, did you buy a green carpet?
Alice:我好像把你的拆错了
Alice: I think I unpacked yours by mistake
Katrina: 拆呗没关系啊
Katrina: It's fine, no worries
Alice:但是我你叫什么
Alice: But I... What's your name again?
Alice:就是你是小叉吗
Alice: Are you Little Fork?
Katrina: 小叉
Katrina: Little Fork
Alice:啊就是你的
Alice: Ah, that's your...
Alice:呃收件名
Alice: Um, recipient name
Katrina: 没有写他
Katrina: Didn't write his name
Alice:那我是
Alice: Then I...
Alice:找一下
Alice: Let me check
Alice:哦果然拿错了
Alice: Oh, I did take the wrong one
Alice:我把那个地毯给你
Alice: I'll give you that carpet
Alice:我说怎么感觉好像跟我印象不太一样
Alice: I was wondering why it felt different from what I remembered
Tasha: 感觉
Tasha: Feels like
Tasha: 应该没问题
Tasha: It should be fine
Tasha: 我觉得烤出来东西都不会难吃
Tasha: I think nothing baked will taste bad
Tasha: 是的还没开罐呢咱们
Tasha: Yes, we haven't opened the can yet
Tasha: 那你今天吃吗
Tasha: Are you eating today?
Alice:这个是你买的吧
Alice: This is what you bought, right?
Alice:哎
Alice: Hey
其他人：我
Others: I
Jake:没有小车
Jake: No small cart
Jake:你得走去
Jake: You have to walk
Jake:可以啊
Jake: Yes, you can
其他人:可以啊那怎么没有小车
Others: Yes, but why no small cart?
其他人:等一会拿麦当劳的时候一起
Others: Let's pick up McDonald's together later
其他人:麦当劳肯定不在一个地方啊
Others: McDonald's won't be in the same place for sure
Alice:他在哪呢
Alice: Where is it?
Jake:对他们有几个地方
Jake: Right, they have several locations
其他人：但确实
Others: But indeed
Alice:啊你
Alice: Ah you
Alice:这个是你买的吧
Alice: This is what you bought, right?
Katrina: 对对对哎
Katrina: Yes, yes, hey
Katrina: 还挺好看没事
Katrina: Looks pretty good, no worries
Alice:不好意思
Alice: Sorry.
其他人：麦当劳有跑腿吗
Others: Does McDonald's do deliveries?
Tasha: 还没点呢
Tasha: Haven't ordered yet.
Tasha: 哎旺仔牛奶呢
Tasha: Hey, where's the Wangzai milk?
Tasha: 哦这呢
Tasha: Oh, here it is.
Tasha: 旺仔牛奶
Tasha: Wangzai milk.
其他人:啊没关系啊
Others: Ah, it's okay.
Tasha: 对
Tasha: Yeah.
其他人:不知道
Others: Don't know.
其他人:感觉只有修硕能干出来这种事情
Others: Feels like only Shure can do something like this.
Tasha: 其他人：
Tasha: Others:
Tasha: 不用了就这样吧
Tasha: No need, just leave it.
其他人：你之前是否加放的
Others: Did you add it before?
Tasha: 加旺仔牛奶更好吃
Tasha: Adding Wangzai milk makes it tastier.
Alice:别把我的狗踢翻了
Alice: Don't knock over my dog.
其他人:不敢想象在这烧狗晚上得多丑
Others: Can't imagine how ugly it would be to roast a dog here at night. 社会问题
其他人:哎我靠
Others: Oh my gosh.
其他人:不敢想象在这烧烤得有多少在这烧
Others: Can't imagine how many would be roasting here.
Alice:在这烧烤
Alice: Roasting here.
Alice:手都快抡冒烟了
Alice: My hands are almost smoking from turning.
Lucia: 不是那为啥还是
Lucia: But then why is it still...
Lucia: 欢迎欢迎
Lucia: Welcome, welcome.
Lucia: 我提亲啊
Lucia: I'm proposing.
Jake:因为这是最后一个我再给你们
Jake: Because this is the last one, I'll give it to you all.
Jake:这全加上
Jake: Add it all.
Lucia: 太奇怪了
Lucia: So weird.
Lucia: 能把它关掉吗
Lucia: Can you turn it off?
Jake:哈哈哈我再加几个
Jake: Hahaha, I'll add a few more.
Jake:好吧让大家一起尴尬
Jake: Okay, let's all be embarrassed together.
Lucia: 对对对大家全都加上去
Lucia: Yeah, yeah, add them all.
Jake:好好好好欢迎欢迎
Jake: Alright, alright, welcome, welcome.
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Lucia: 欢迎各位底金
Lucia: Welcome everyone.
Jake:哈哈哈欢迎修硕
Jake: Hahaha, welcome Shure.
Lucia: 这怎么关啊
Lucia: How do you turn this off?
Alice:应该还有一个小差
Alice: There should be a small lever.
Shure: 人人家以为我抵制他抵制
Shure: Everyone thinks I'm boycotting, boycotting.
其他人:坏了艾斯克尔又又过不了
Others: Oh no, Esker won't make it again.
Jake:抵制什么呀
Jake: Boycotting what?
Jake:你要抵制什么呀哈哈
Jake: What are you boycotting? Haha.
其他人：不要再说了
Others: Stop talking.
其他人：：再说skrryvu又过不了
Others: Keep talking and skrryvu won't pass.
Shure: 抵制通货膨胀的
Shure: Resist inflation.
其他人:再说我又要打打打款机了
Others: If you keep talking, I'll have to use the punching machine again.
Alice:啊
Alice: Ah.
Alice:在这儿
Alice: Here.
Alice:对不起
Alice: Sorry.
Jake:先加一个修硕
Jake: Add Shure first.
Jake:就用你的这个
Jake: Just use this.
Jake:你你你PPT里面那照片怎么样
Jake: How about the photo in your PPT?
Shure: 什么好
Shure: It's fine.
Jake:你PPT砸码的
Jake: Your PPT with the watermark.
其他人:打码的打码
Others: Watermark, watermark.
Jake:砸码的
Jake: The watermark.
Shure: 你别打码的了
Shure: Stop with the watermark.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Shure: typecody
Shure: Typecody.
Shure: 证件照吧
Shure: A passport photo, right?
Alice:可没送到
Alice: It wasn't delivered.
Lucia: 他有可能也落下了
Lucia: He might have missed it too.
Lucia: 他把我好多快递都落下了
Lucia: He missed a lot of my packages.
Katrina: no
Katrina: No.
Lucia: 然后他还非说他取了
Lucia: And he insisted he picked them up.
Katrina: 我靠竟然是两个
Katrina: Oh my god, there are two!
Lucia: 啊哪个哪个女生
Lucia: Which girl?
Jake:他不知道群里不知道是什么人
Jake: He doesn't know who the people in the group are.
Katrina: 日
Katrina: Damn.
Lucia: 对群里不知道是谁
Lucia: Right, he doesn't know who they are.
其他人:我靠这是什么
Others: Oh my god, what is this?
Katrina: 本把手的这个
Katrina: This handle.
其他人:我靠这么帅
Others: Damn, so cool.
Katrina: 啊占便宜
Katrina: Ah, taking advantage.
Katrina: 竟然是两个吗
Katrina: There are actually two?
Jake:走我们去取
Jake: Let's go pick it up.
其他人:走走let's go
Others: Let's go, let's go.
Jake:走
Jake: Let's go.
其他人:let's go
Others: Let's go.
Lucia: 那也可以先去取然后行
Lucia: We can go pick it up first, then it's fine.
Alice:露西啊
Alice: Lucia.
Jake:我先问一下这个你的胶到了吗
Jake: Let me ask you first, did your glue arrive?
Alice:露西啊你的胶到了吗
Alice: Lucia, did your glue arrive?
Lucia: 我的胶他没给我取
Lucia: No, they didn't bring it to me.
Lucia: 那个那个取快递的那个
Lucia: The, the person who picks up the deliveries.
Alice:我这个胶不知道好使不好使点胶
Alice: I don't know if this glue works well for applying it.
Alice:我去试试就这种
Alice: I'll go try it out, this kind.
Lucia: 哦我们一会会去取
Lucia: Oh, we'll go pick it up later.
Alice:我们一会会去取
Alice: We'll go pick it up later.
Alice:哎我先试试这个能贴不能吧
Alice: Let me try this first to see if it sticks.
Alice:哎呦
Alice: Ouch.
Tasha: 儿童餐的不是金枪鱼
Tasha: The kid's meal doesn't have tuna.
Tasha: 拌饭的那个
Tasha: The one with the rice.
Tasha: 拌饭叫对
Tasha: The rice mix, yes.
Tasha: 那个好吃
Tasha: That one's tasty.
Tasha: 对我一般就吃这两个
Tasha: Yeah, I usually just eat those two.
Tasha: 你可以在配料里面不要玉米
Tasha: You can get it without corn in the ingredients.
Tasha: 哎呦哎呦
Tasha: Oh no, oh no.
Tasha: 取麦当劳吗
Tasha: Should we pick up McDonald's?
Tasha: 麦当劳不是送到门口吗
Tasha: Doesn't McDonald's deliver to the door?
Tasha: 我选择这里
Tasha: I'll choose here.
Tasha: 走去哪里
Tasha: Where are we going?
Lucia: 原来你不知道
Lucia: So you didn't know.
Tasha: 可以
Tasha: Okay.
Tasha: 不是带壳
Tasha: Not with shells.
Tasha: 什么
Tasha: What?
Tasha: 没吃过熔岩草莓就是
Tasha: You've never had molten strawberry, like...
Tasha: 那就第一排
Tasha: Then the first row.
Alice:那第一排福袋好
Alice: Then the first row of lucky bags is good.
Alice:你你赢过去吧
Alice: You, you take it.
Tasha: 行你倒吧
Tasha: Okay, you pour.
Tasha: 倒个8分满就行
Tasha: Just fill it up to 80%.
Tasha: 哎你没关系
Tasha: It's okay.
Tasha: 你就把倒满12个就行
Tasha: Just fill all 12 evenly.
Tasha: 均匀一点即可
Tasha: Make them even.